progressive science is a totalizing
religion and by the way it's a jealous
religion there were there was a video
went viral over the weekend
some of these leftist rioters in
portland holding up blm signs
decided to burn a stack of bibles they
burned a stack
of bibles they burned american flags too
but why would they burn the bible
if you are still viewing the blm riots
and the continued lockdowns and the
closing of churches but the opening of
leftist political rallies and the
closing of normal funerals
but the opening of only a couple
funerals of leftist idols
if you're still viewing that with
befuddlement as though gosh that's a
weird quirk of politics i wonder why
that's happening
you're not understanding the moment
if however you realize that all these
little events are completely connected
and they go down
not just to the political level but
deeper to the cultural level and
ultimately to the religious level
then you'll see what's going on there's
a great line i quoted on this show
frequently from henry edward cardinal
manning the line is
all human conflict is ultimately
theological everybody's got to serve
somebody
like cult and culture come from the same
root word what a culture
worships will define that culture we are
ultimately not arguing over
tax rates as tax rates or health care
policy as health care policy
we're we are arguing over first quest
principles
ultimate questions over what is the
nature of man what kind of society do we
want
i say that on the show that's why i'm
not totally interested in just like
owning the libs all the time i mean it's
super fun and i enjoy it when i can
but what i want in debate actually is to
get down to the root question because
we're not really debating the things we
pretend to be debating
we're debating fundamental issues of
society
and what the right is saying what
conservatives are saying is we want a
society grounded in
our traditional religion and in our
traditional society in our practices and
at a political level in
constitutionalism
where we can debate political issues and
vote for our representatives and have
power as we the people
that's what the conservatives want what
the progressives are saying is
christianity is all bunk it's actually
it's frankly it's terrible it's not only
false but it's terrible
and traditional religion is if you
believe in god you're a total idiot
you've got to believe in science with a
capital s and a trademark over the e and
you got to believe in darwin our
wonderful prophet
and all that matters is our ideology
and if you're still a conservative
you're a knuckle dragger and
we can't let those stupid people have
free choice we can't let those bitter
clingers those deplorables those
irredeemable americans
have free choice we're the experts we
know better than everybody
so we're just going to put some white
lab coats on some people and have them
make all the decisions for us and
hopefully those rubes get with the
program because it'll be better for
everybody
and frankly it's inevitable because
we're on the right side of history and
all these other people are going to go
to the dust bin of history and
and they're going to be forgotten and
they're going to die out and that'll be
a wonderful thing
those are the two ways of looking at
politics
which side are you on i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts